- All right y'all, I'm back
with producer extraordinaire
Norman Lear.
- Yes!
- And you know my next guest
as the hilarious scene stealer
from "The Mindy Project".
Her new Netflix special, "Sweet and Salty"
is out right now.
Take a look.
- My entire family
loved eating at Hooters.
Even my mom liked eating at Hooters
because you could buy a wheel barrow
of wings for four dollars.
She's like, "Everybody's rich at Hooters".
However she wasn't always willing to admit
that she liked Hooters.
I have been to Hooters my entire life.
Not with me, I have never
been to Hooters.
I'm like, "You recruited my
babysitter at a Hooters".
(laughs)
(audience cheering)
- Please welcome Fortune Feimster.
(happy music)
(audience clapping)
- That's for you.
- All right.
- Yes!
Have a seat.
- Okay, thank you.
- Hi!
- Oh my gosh!
- Ah, you're so funny!
- Thank you!
- Oh my god, I love you.
Meet Norman Lear, yes.
- How are you?
- Oh I'm so-
- Ow!
(laughs)
- I'm so strong.
- He was cracking up.
We're both cracking up
- Oh good!
- watching you and your
Hooters spiel, I love it.
- I'm between two legends, right now.
- No, not the same, not the same at all.
- Oh my gosh, what a treat.
- I'll take it,
but totally a lie.
Your accent always reminds me of home.
I always love when I run into you.
It just feels-
So where did you grow up?
- I grew up in North Carolina.
My mom made me be a debutant,
that's how southern I am.
- You're a southern bell.
- I am.
- You're a southern bell,
wait what did that entail.
What did you have to do?
Oh my gosh!
- [Fortune] I was like, "what happened!?".
- You are so fancy right now!
- Yeah, I had to wear
a white wedding gown.
- Oh my god, you were
like from the bricks,
I was from the sticks, girl.
We didn't have anything like that.
- But we had no money.
That was the thing, my mom had been one
and then we lost all our money.
It happens.
- It happens!
- You know, gambling.
(laughing)
And then she still wanted me to carry on
this tradition of being a,
pretending to be rich and
then go to etiquette classes.
- That's amazing.
- Etiquette classes?
- Yeah, I had to learn how to be a lady.
(laughter)
I didn't know, I didn't
know, I had to like-
- I don't!
- Dab my face with a napkin.
You know, you just can't wipe
your face like a monster!
(laughing)
- Obviously I didn't
attend etiquette classes.
- All right, well I still to this day,
people are like, "You
should never eat in public".
'Cause it's not great.
(laughing)